Bueno mi nombre es yasuri Martínez
Álvarez y vengo del Estado de Hidalgo Ya
nos dijeron que solamente era tres horas
caminando que teníamos que pasar por un
maizal y por ciudad
me estaban cobrando $6,000 dólares
estadounidenses Nos llevaron en una
carretera
donde no pasaba casi ningún carro y
cuando ya llegamos nos dijeron que nos
teníamos que bajar corriendo Entonces
nosotros Nos bajamos corriendo estaba
como que una zanja y nosotros no lo
vimos porque está oscuro y nos fuimos
después de ahí seguimos corriendo pero
como era zacate bajito cada que pasaba
un carro nos teníamos que acostar en el
piso para que no nos viera
después nos agarró la migra
nos agarró nos dijo que que hacíamos ahí
nos pidió nuestras identificaciones y
nos llevó detenidos